a friend of mine said i i just see
humans
as a
like a bunch of holes that just walk a
walk around
it's
not untrue
it's a funny way to look at humans so we
have ears we have nose
uh we have mouth
we have
um the sexual holes vagina penis
and then uh
you know what's the uh medical term for
your [ __ ]
anus anus thank you
uh this is this is a very technical
discussion the rectum's further in don't
confuse the two oh that's very important
what what
is there a difference between throat and
mouth
by the way so when you say throat are we
talking about
when that hole actually became becomes
tubular
so the throat i would count as just sort
of the very back of the of the you know
the back of the mouth where the nose
also comes down and meets it uh where
the tonsils are and the uvula
but you're right that you know we are a
bunch of holes but more accurately we're
a tube right we start in the womb as
kind of this microscopic little disc
almost like a a uh
you know a flat bread and then we're we
roll in almost like a burrito into this
tube and we're a simple microscopic tube
and from there we grow into this bigger
and bigger tube and we become more
complicated and each end of the tube
does split into various holes so all the
holes you mentioned at the front end of
the tube the front end of our body right
it splits into the nose
the mouth the ears the sinuses the the
tube to the lungs which is the windpipe
the tube down to the stomach which is
the esophagus
and then the other end of the tube
splits as well uh you know men end up
with two holes
and women end up with three holes
um you know the urethra the vagina and
the anus and men just you know the
urethra and kind of the reproductive
system they share a hole so i'm learning
a lot today
it really is incredible that you start
from sperm and egg and you have some dna
information and from that the building
project begins
and then what that leads to
is like a like a like pizza dough and
then you roll it
into a tube and that tube then
um eventually
sort of becomes more and more
complicated and gets eyes and a brain
and then uh can create a twitter account
so for so from
it's it's really incredible that we're
just a fancy tube
right we are and we sprout eyes and a
brain and a sense of smell and taste
pretty much to regulate what comes in
the front of the tube you know we don't
want to eat anything dangerous or
poisonous you know we want to choose
what we eat
even choose who we kiss well we seem to
be motivated by what comes out of the
tube as well
in part
that's not just output it's a feedback
mechanism seemingly like we're also
monitoring the functioning of the output
we're not just obsessed about the input
we're very obsessed with the output
absolutely right about that
uh people you know have medical
complaints about their output very often
that are you know i'm never i never
cease to be surprised by a new kind of
complaint or observation about the
output i think people have gone to wars
over
the output and uh maybe sometimes the
lack of the output or the desire for
output for the particular other humans
um that your you fancy the brain and the
eyes that sprouted somehow convinced
the
the rest of the body that this one
particular other tube is fanciful so
you're going to go to major wars and
lead global suffering because because of
the fancy and the desire for additional
output with the other
tube
you